when the last topics we'll talk about
here as we're going through you know
what's going on right now with who World
Health Organization your Trump said were
pulling out of the World Health
Organization that's 400 million dollars
of funding every year that they're gonna
be putting in that they were putting
into World Health Organization he said
we're leaving and a bite and I think
just tweeted out something about this
today I don't know if you saw Biden's to
eat whether he tweeted out or somebody
else Biden said Americas are safer when
America is engaged in strengthening
global health on my first day as
president I will rejoin the World Health
Organization and restore our leadership
on the world stage what are your
thoughts about Trump defunding 400
million dollars from World Health
Organization all I gotta say is this
Trump's pull out game is strong let me
tell you why let me tell you why I'm
glad that Trump is pulling out because
we've been getting screwed the entire
time who is the number one funder of the
World Health Organization who the United
States it's the United States number two
is it's the old Gates we fund everything
and what does who do who comes out and
wants to condemn us who was the one if
you remember who is the one that lobbied
for China for us to keep all of our art
our airports open to Chinese travelers
right it was who that lobbied on behalf
of the Chinese government and Trump had
to go back to them and say hey listen up
why is it that you're biting the hand
that feeds you what does China give you
but you're gonna come over and you're
gonna work against us who knew the
entire time who had the information that
China had that this was a problem and
what do they do they keep their mouth
shut
they keep their mouth shut and so Trump
finally said screw it if you're gonna
bite our hand we're not gonna feed you
anymore I say kudos to Trump to having a
big pair of orange pumpkins Daniel in
there between his knees to actually do
whatever pee
won't do and that is pullout from who
because we're tired of getting screwed
let me respond back to that Joshua so
you brought up a point earlier that what
was the one issue that all Democrats and
Republicans agreed upon Pat what was
that issue
China China okay now what is the other
issue that all Democrats and the
majority of the GOP are basically coming
back saying this is not a good decision
it's this it's pulling out of the World
Health Organization basically the u.s.
Republicans we can check the math on
that let me just get on to my point
Congress is pushing back big time okay
we have a group of more than 700 experts
I'm gonna use the key word here
experts basically saying this is a
horrible decision experts on what can I
get to my point you just went rant
enough let me tell you something about
that this is my problem with Donald
Trump and I'm gonna use someone very
close to the top administration to prove
my point you're ready for this go ahead
who is Trump's longest chief of staff
longest standing chief of staff it was
rice brevis for like 30 minutes
who and then two who came in longest
standing chief of staff chief of staff
your Trump guy who is his chief of staff
for two years
he's only been president for three and a
half years who's president who would she
was that for two years not Kelly yes I'm
talking about General John Kelly so
here's an ears of General John Kelly's
story Pat how do we know each other
Limor insurance conference no no now Bob
now but we assist each other now but
every year was now but last year last
November Orlando Dallas it was in Dallas
and I came by to Europe yes arm I'm
gonna let me tell you something I came
to your office that day mm-hmm and you
know that night I left here the office
and I went and had dinner with the
founder that one of the owners of ins
Marc mm-hmm okay so I'm sitting there
with David Grant his name run-ins Marc
guy telling me why he's a big Trump guy
and I'm like huh you know I'm not a big
Trump guy not so much I got nothing
tell he's going he's going and we look
over and who's sitting behind us by
himself
doing nothing who general John Kelly he
was speaking at now
straight up he was the guest speaker at
now but so me and Dave grant again he's
going in on why he's a big Trump
supporter and he says to me that guy
looks like General John Kelly check your
facts I say you know me I'll go ask
anyone anything I say hey sir you uh I
mean sit he's sitting where Louisa's
like five feet away hmm
I say hey sir you here for now but he
goes yeah yes I am I go are you
attending now buddies like no not really
I go are you General John Kelly goes yes
I am I go wow that's that's crazy like
we were just talking about Trump so
here's my story general John Kelly you
can check to check my math on this he's
from Boston so was Dave grant so we do a
little quick introduction are you from
Boston hi Boston I had the cheese bar
that thought that Boston Boston we get
to know each other I say hey can I buy
you a drink sure double vodka on the
rocks boom he's about your drinking a
double vodka well you've never had a
vodka before
double vodka five minutes later he goes
I'll do another boom by the guy to
double but this is General John Kelly
chief of staff from 2017 in charge time
we thought you were Republican cuts
connected so go ahead sometimes I was a
guy so I'm honored I'm meeting him he's
beat you know he's being open but kind
of playing it close to the vest and me
you know I like to pry ask questions and
I say we speak for about an hour so
what's the point of my story so I say
hey general Kelly do you mind if I ask
you a couple wrap-up questions here I go
would you do me a favor would you tell
me what you absolutely loved about
working for president Trump and also if
you don't mind tell me what you really
did not like about working for president
John Cho Donald Trump he looks me square
in the eye and he goes I can't tell you
one thing I liked about working with
Donald off square in the eye
this is his chief of staff and I go WOW
just that face yeah he goes and I'll
tell you why he goes anyone who thinks
they know it all and does not listen to
experts I cannot respect he so let me
tell you something I am a general I've
been a general for years I bring in
experts on the regular I bring in people
as his chief of staff people are experts
in their field expert on China experts
on Russia experts
technology experts experts experts Trump
would remove them and say I know what
I'm doing so he goes this is his chief
of staff this is not opinion he says I
couldn't work for a guy like that what
are you going with us that's my point is
that Trump is pulling out of the World
Health Organization
he has experts I said the beginning of
this rant he has experts telling this is
not the thing to do but Trump is going
with his gut he thinks he knows it all
he doesn't know everything breaking news
Donald Trump doesn't know anything or
everything or anything for that many go
ahead shovel this bull crap right okay
so if you're gonna do something you're
gonna tell me that the general Kelly
chief of staff by the way he went on to
now but to give that speech and it was a
little more watered down version of that
basically saying you need to listen to
experts people that know what they're
talking about here's my final point are
you a life insurance expert would you
say that yes you're a life insurance
expert how much do you know life
settlements I'd listen to you you would
listen to me all right you would listen
to me how an expert at this I have you
said hey I got a life insurance guy is
gonna sell it tell me another thing or
you would call me in as an actor would
that's my point is that you know your
stuff but if there's a little part of
that that you're weren't so sure about
you're calling an expert we've got a
pretty good staff here that works in the
tech department but we were unsure of
what sling the other day so we brought
in a sling expert to teach our stuff to
teach our staff so my point would Trump
is this Yukie can be a great leader he
can be a mag a guy he can be an orange
cartoon whatever you want to think about
him how much you need to look into
experts but how much do you know about
the World Health Organisation you got to
what I'm saying is you need to listen to
experts and my point here the World
Health Organization is I'm using the
World Health Organization Joey Ted Ross
and woody know what his reputation is
very humble and I mean that's not it
that's not a pretty thing ladies
literally him you have to be with or let
me go
just know Patrick is the CEO of two
wonderful companies one of them being
value tainment he brings me on board of
value team it because I am an expert at
certain things because
as Patrick understands that there's some
things that even a lowly little peasant
mere peasant like Joshua Fierstein
wouldn't know that Patrick doesn't know
and yes Patrick as a CEO of the company
brings people into his room to get their
opinion but when it comes down to it
guess who signed in the check that man
right there and so guess who makes a
decision right there guess whose name is
on the line right there okay
guess whose reputation in any one of his
companies its Hill on the line when all
is said and done
Trump was elected president John Kelly
not elected president he was not King
bro he was elected president exactly
within the bounds of the Constitution he
is going to make decisions you just said
yourself you just said yourself if Trump
were to implement the digital tracking
laws you wouldn't vote for him vote
exactly so what is active what is this
you can't just agree with everything
Trump does because you just said
yourself that there's certain things you
would disagree with you just say what
you have on immigration do you not do
you not disagree with Trump on
immigration no sir
you don't I I said I don't believe gone
I don't believe everything that the
conservatives say about immigration but
let's go back let's go back to two Trump
I elected Trump to make decisions for me
I if I elect him I'm not going to
question it and if I do question it then
I'm not going to vote for him the next
time the thing that I'm saying is all of
this talk about experts experts experts
in the end Trump is the one that puts
the pen to the paper he's the one that
America voted for and it's him that's
making the decision he can consult
experts all he wants but he was elected
for a reason you're missing
he wasn't even consulting with the
experts is my by the way if you're
watching this click thumbs up if you
agree with Josh click thumbs down if you
agree with Adam okay I'm curious but now
hear me out thumbs up I get the I'm just
if we're right I'm gonna let me let me
give my perspective on this let me give
my perspective on this you have a good
point but you
you don't have enough information on
World Health Organization where that
wasn't my partner but my point is about
John Kelly I care about a great story of
meeting Noble you have to care about WH
er because the topic we're talking about
is WH oh I'm talking about experts I
understand you're on the piece of paper
a group of more than 700 experts on
global everybody's an expert on anything
no that's not true a group of 700
experts now you have to realize World
Health Organization will start in 1948
by you know Truman and Truman say
Democrat himself and it's a form of a
control and bring the world together and
let's all represent this and you know at
this point of the game
china has given a lot of money to world
health ed Ross reports everything to
China Ted Cruz keeps Tom on how China's
doing everything right
when coronavirus came out at the
beginning Ted Rose went to China I came
back publicly to the world says I am so
impressed by the way China is handling
the coronavirus this is the guy that
runs to World Health Organization
telling to the world I'm so impressed by
the way China is handling this situation
either he has to be fired or you have to
defund a fire like a form of defunding
is a form of firing you he doesn't have
the ability to fire he doesn't Trump
doesn't run World Organization he can
say I'm taking 400 million out then now
I won't have influence on who we really
like today running the World Health
Organization then it comes back to money
it could be a simple six-month pause and
we're coming back depending on that guy
getting fired but the part I agree with
you let me take the part I agree with
them okay let me tell you about part I
agree with them okay uh some people are
agreeing with you about though if you
look at the thumbs up and thumbs down
this depart I agree with you okay
I don't think Trump can be in the room
with anybody that's ahead of him
I don't think he can do that because
he's an egomaniac or what Wow I mean
listen go back to the talk that he gave
at Wharton Business School and Gregg
cher said that Trump got up and says all
you guys gonna be successful but not as
successful as me he is one of the most
ambitious competitive guys you'll ever
meet there's levels to the game I'll
give him that
okay so he thinks he knows best
that's dangerous but that you can't call
it that you can call it that but it's
his style of leadership that's work his
entire life you can't tell him to change
at this point when America elected this
guy they elected a guy
had a show saying you're fired they
elected a guy that says I'll fix it all
and everyone is a based on it but they
totally so what I'm sorry we're also
rooting against okay no actually she was
not a horrible Kennedy yes she was a she
wasn't a best friend anymore ratings she
wasn't a terrible Kennedy she was a very
person with a big resume but the point
is America said we want somebody like it
let's see what decisions you're gonna
make he professionally fired people his
entire life of course Trump is known for
somebody that fires very quickly he
doesn't have any prompt firing people
quickly and he comes I can replace it
with somebody this is in a game show
though who's Gary Moochie and I sat down
and we spoke you know yeah you know how
long you know how long he had a job
eight days you've if that yeah he says I
came in I was fired I don't what the
hell happened right here
yeah it's Trump style so that's his
style you mean like him you may not like
him but that's a style and but he can't
can't fire the WHI but he can be yeah he
can look anybody funny do you think it's
good to defund it I think it is for now
he did he didn't do this overnight Pat
he did this in three stages three three
warnings he gave the who he said we're
gonna pause your funding we're gonna
withdraw it and then we're gonna
withdraw from the World Health
Organization he gave them three
opportunities to get rid of the guy at
the top because The Associated Press
leaked documents that show that who knew
about the virus and even told the
scientist in China not to talk about
anything anymore these documents were
leaked so of course he's gonna do that
and let me just say this about Trump's
leadership style okay I have talked with
people that were in the room when he sat
down and sought advice from people about
whether or not he should move the
embassy to Jerusalem you remember that
was a huge news story it was a huge
thing do you think he did the right
thing to want to do what move it to
Jerusalem yes I think yes okay so from
my source inside the White House they
said this they said that Trump sat there
and said okay let's go around the table
I want you to tell me do you think I
should move it do you think I should
move it and every single person around
the table said no you want to know why
they said no it's not politically
expedient for you it's not the right
thing what Trump said he said
you guys gave me all political reasons
none of you told me whether it was the
right or wrong thing to do this is a
promise we've been making to our ally
for a long time don't you think it's
time that we deliver on our promises
we're gonna go ahead and do it and you
know what he did he made a stronger ally
in Israel and he followed through on a
promise that every other liar president
has said for the last Froman I don't
know how many years okay so ladies you
have stronger ally with Israel it
depends on United States it wasn't like
we love you we love you even more now
like we depend on you so I know we're
exactly okay what are you what are you
saying my point is if even if he didn't
move the embassy Israel would still be
there as an ally as you know I said he
made a stronger ally him and I will have
a decent relationship I mean it's not
like they don't have a relation by the
way your cousin shot out your cousin
Jared young Josh's cousin here shot
[Music]